well we spoke today to the shadow
immigration minister stephen kinnick who
was on the program today i started by
asking him if he backed the strikes
what we need to do is keep focused on
the government because it is the
government's job to make these talks
work it's actually in the contract
between train operators and the
government that industrial action
should only take place at the direction
of the government and the decisions the
operators make should be at the
direction of the secretary of state for
transport but boris johnson and grant
shaps have been completely absent from
these talks and from this process and
that's because they want these strikes
to happen so i think our job as labour
mps as the parliamentary labour party is
to stay focused on the government to
make it clear that it's the government's
job to get people around the table and
that i think has to be the singular
focus of what we're saying and doing in
parliament it's it's pretty clear um
that's the kind of line from labour i
guess what i'm still struggling to
understand is labour's actual position
on the strikes i'll rephrase it if you
are an rmt member would you be voting
for action
yes i would be because i think that um
the
there is the right to strike and it's
really important that workforces have
that right to strike we believe that
uh rail workers health workers people
working in every industry that has done
so much as well to keep our economy
going through the pandemic have the
right to strike and to fight for a
better deal and what was really
incredible today was to learn that the
government is looking to lift the cap on
bankers bonuses so whilst they're
preaching uh to those who've kept our
economy going through the pandemic that
they have to exercise wage restraint
they are telling the bankers uh that
it's all right to just carry on raking
it in it's breathtaking hypocrisy and i
think what we really saw today is where
the government's priorities lie um
we believe in uh working people getting
a good deal in terms of pay terms and
conditions a strike is a last resort for
getting that but sometimes that's what
you have to do well i've been listening
to you it sounds like you you do agree
with uh you know their right to strike
you know your pro worker that if you're
an rmt uh member you would vote to
strike that people deserve to you know
get paid
at the level that they should be um
do you think that case thomas must judge
it a bit then because actually if you
look at the polling you know there is
more support for the strikes and perhaps
some would expect 37 support than
according to yougov do you think he's
misjudged the public mood
i think he's got it absolutely right
actually because he has said very
clearly that his job and the job of
labour mps and the parliamentary party
is to keep the focus on the government
oh come on he hasn't he hasn't been very
he failed he's been very careful uh not
back the strikes to tell labour mps they
shouldn't be joining picket lines and to
effectively you know
move away from the debate we need to
keep our fire on the conservative
government and the way in which they
have failed uh to get the strikes off
the get the talks off the ground to stop
these strikes from happening and the
reason is because they want the strikes
to happen kier i think has called that
out really effectively and i think the
way he's done that has really cut
through with the british people okay um
so you're saying that you want the
government to get involved to get around
the negotiating table so what would
labour do then the rmt wants to see a
pay rise of seven percent to
effectively match uh inflation last year
when they were being negotiated um
would you agree to a seven percent pay
rise
it's not our job as labour mps to tell
the rmt what is a deal that they would
accept
i'm asking if you were in government you
are asking the government to get
involved if you were in government would
you accept a seven percent pay rise it's
also not the job of government to
publicly say what the outcome of
negotiation should be those negotiations
have to take place around a table where
there's trust between all of the uh key
parties are you happy with a ten percent
pay rise though do you think that's the
right ballpark
well the rmt has to be very clear on
what its bottom line is uh and to be
able to take a deal back to its
workforce that can be approved and it's
for the workforce to know they are the
hard-working uh
people in our rail industry that have
kept our economy going through the
packaging
they know better than we do uh what is
the best deal for them and what works
for them okay and teaching unions are
also a balloting for strike action we've
heard from the unions there that they
want in their words inflation busting
pay rise 11.7
currently the offer is 3
would you agree to an 11.7 rise for
teachers what we've seen is people
taking a real terms pay cut and
inflation of course plays a role in that
but what i would first of all say is
should those bankers be having their the
cap lifted on their boat
who are making over half a million
pounds a year let's have some level
in the salaries let's have some leveling
up and some justice in the way in which
our economy works like we know that you
would like to see the cap on bantis
bonuses we know that you think that the
chief executive network is paid too much
11.7 for teachers is that fair
i think we have to have a deal for the
teaching unions to take back to their
members that they would find acceptable
specifically in the public sector would
you like to see pay rises for the public
sector matching inflation
i want to see the public sector getting
a fair deal and that is something they
have not had for many many years we've
had 12 years of tory austerity
12 years of public sector pay freezes
and that has led us to a situation where
the workforce is demotivated demoralized
they pulled out all the stops to get our
country through the pandemic and they
deserve some justice and they deserve
some fair play and i think that's not
that much to ask so the government has
to be ready to come forward with a
policy on pay that is going to work for
public sector workers but they also need
to have policies to grow our economy
what's labor's policy on pay then well
we're not in government so we don't we
we need to
see the government engaging with the
public sector but we've been clear that
our public sector pay freezes were not
the right way to go and we've been clear
all the way through that public the
public sector pay should be in line with
inflation now of course we're seeing
inflation uh going through the roof
and so we are going to have to have a
compromise which is based on giving
people the fairest possible deal that we
can get in difficult economic
circumstances but we also need to go to
see the government taking action to get
inflation down that means getting a much
better deal in terms of trading with the
european union than we currently have
because the price of imports are going
through the roof it means taking v80 off
energy bills it means growing the
economy investing in
productive sectors like wind farms and
uh insulating people's homes so that you
actually create good jobs driving up
productivity that's the only way to
really deal with inflation in the long
term and have much more sustainable
growth so the government has to do these
two things a fair deal for our workers
combined with pro-growth and
pro-sustainability policies